seis meses de pandemia y restricciones
sociales ahora a la crisis económica se
suma el hartazgo en muchos sectores de
la sociedad hace meses brasil se
mantiene como la nación más afectada de
américa latina'
el gigante latinoamericano acumula más
de 4 millones de contagiados a pesar de
las estadísticas prácticamente todos los
estados siguen adelante con sus planes
de apertura para esa pandemia ha durado
más de 6 meses y nadie puede soportarlo
más
méxico es el cuarto país latinoamericano
con más contagios pero el segundo a
nivel de decesos con más de 70.000
fallecidos no obstante seis meses de
paralización en muchos sectores de la
economía llevaron a una recesión cercana
del 13 por ciento si me espantan las
cifras pero rompo quedarme en casa la
verdad mi economía ya no me lo permite
no me lo permiten no no puedo pero es
uno de los casos más preocupantes con
casi 33 millones de habitantes y más de
30.000 fallecidos es el país con la tasa
global más alta de decesos pese a las
cifras alarmantes en esta nación rige
una cuarentena focalizada que muchos
aseguran que no se respetan
otros de los países latinoamericanos en
el centro de la atención es colombia los
casos superan ya los 700.000 pero
septiembre comenzó con una nueva etapa
de flexibilización en las restricciones
si bien las cifras no son lo
suficientemente alentadoras seis meses
de paralización de sectores
fundamentales
sumados a los cambios en la rutina de mí
derivaron en una reapertura ansiada por
muchos bolsillos y mentes